Welcome back to
Academy Dialogues.
It starts with us.
Our next discussion is
on reaching gender equity
in Hollywood.
We are honored to
have lawyer, academic,
and advocate Anita Hill
moderating today's discussion.
Joining Anita, Oscar
winning actor Geena Davis.
Sony Pictures animation
executive and Oscar winning
producer, Karen Rupert Toliver.
Award winning
director Alma Har'el.
And Academy governor and
composer, Laura Karpman.
Onto you, Anita.
Thank you, Sean.
And I want to thank
this fabulous panel who
has agreed to speak with us and
give us some clarity on gender
equality in Hollywood.
I know that one
doesn't start out
as a successful
individual in Hollywood,
so I have a question that I want
to start with everyone here.
At some point in your
lives, I think many of you--
I suppose many of
you, or all of you--
were dreaming about a
career in entertainment.
And as you imagined
that career, I'm
curious about what you
thought it would be like,
and why you were drawn to it?
And finally, just if you could
all just give me briefly,
how you made that dream of
being in Hollywood a reality?
And let's see,
where shall I start?
I'll start with you, Geena.
All right.
Well, you know it turns out
that when I was three years old
I announced to my
parents that I wanted
to be an actor in movies.
And I don't know how I
even knew that people
had jobs at three years old, but
that was it and never changed.
And majored in
acting in college,
and was fortunate enough--
I mean, I did some modeling
and I tried different ways
to get into the business.
But I eventually got to
audition for the movie Tootsie,
and I got cast in sort of
a supporting role in that.
And it was stunning
and mind-blowing,
but at the same
time, well, yeah,
I mean this was what
was supposed to happen.
So everything kind of
flowed out of that.
I moved to LA and that was it.
Was it the same as
what you imagined
when you were three years old?
You know, I'm not really sure
why I became so possessed
with that idea.
I mean, I think in
hindsight, it might
be that I wanted to be able to
pretend to be somebody else.
You know, that I was
very insecure and shy,
and I wanted to live a different
kind of a life than that
and pretend to be other people.
But it's been-- it really
has been a dream come true.
I mean, acting is the thing
that inspires me and drives me.
And I love it.
I really do.
Great.
Laura, as a composer,
a woman composer,
I imagine that you don't
see many role-models.
Or maybe I'm wrong about that.
But so how did you
come to imagine
that you would have a career
in entertainment in Hollywood?
First of all, I can't believe
Anita Hill is asking me
anything.
But let's just move off of that.
I can best Geena
just by a few years
on this one, in that
my mother decided
that I would be a composer
when she was pregnant with me.
So she was a painter,
and she thought
music was the highest art.
And for me-- so there
was not a question
that that would be
something that I would do.
But I thought I was going to
be an East Coast intellectual.
And I grew up in LA, and
my dad was a cardiologist
and he had a lot of
celebrities in his practice,
and a lot of Hollywood people.
But I just--
I didn't think that
that was my dream.
But I was obsessed with drama.
I was obsessed with opera.
I was obsessed with plays,
like I read all of Shakespeare,
I read all of Eugene
O'Neill's plays.
And so I was kind of
moving towards it.
And I went to New
York, and I studied
with the most intellectual
guy that I could find.
But sort of interrupted
by that, I went to France
and studied with a very
famous teacher of composers.
Her name was Nadia Boulanger.
And she was great.
She was very old by
the time I got there,
but she was great
friends with Stravinsky.
And she had trained Aaron
Copland, and Piazzolla
and a lot of great composers.
And she was surrounded by women.
So it wasn't just her.
It was Louise Talma, who
was an American composer.
And Mademoiselle, who I don't
know what her last name was.
I'm not sure she
actually had one.
But she taught like
really hard caught
ear training, which is kind of
technical work for composers.
And I think I realize
now in retrospect
that I had these
models that popped up.
There were never any certainly
no Hollywood composers
that you knew of, and really
no concert music composers
that you knew of.
And now we know of course
they've been around,
but they just have
been made invisible.
So you know, I
pursued this dream
and then wound up at Sundance as
kind of their new music person.
And then from then
on, I fell in love
with scoring the picture and
the rest is a work in progress.
Let's put it that way.
Well, it sounds
like for both of you
it was really a lot of work.
It wasn't a sort of
instant story of success
that you read about or
hear about in the movies.
I think that's the only
place you hear about that.
You know, the truth is I think
for everybody that it's always
a long hard road.
And you pop at certain times
and you don't at other times.
So Karen, I'm not even sure
that until about a year ago
I knew what a producer was.
When did you know that
you could be a producer
or would be a producer?
You know, it's
interesting, because I
think I've even grown to
a better awareness of what
a producer is just in life.
You know, I'm just sort
of making things happen.
When I was young, I
wanted to be in the arts.
But my parents were scientists,
and so I kind of had that--
I kind of had a bundle
of contradictions
that I was very
confident internally,
but I was really
shy on the outside.
So I was trying to
kind of figure out--
I knew I wanted to
be in the industry,
and I finally got the confidence
to kind of come out here.
And then looked at the list
of crew names of people
at the end of the
credits and tried
to figure out where I fit in.
And through that
exploration, I realized
that the putting it together
and the literally producing
and making something
come out of nothing
was something that was sort
of natural to my personality.
And did it mostly as a
studio exec for 20 years
until I got the chance
to do this short.
And I realized that
this really was
what I was sort of destined--
at least in my mind--
to do is to sort of make
something appear out
of nothing against all odds.
That really kind
of, to me, became
what it meant to be a producer.
And I think every day I become
more sort of aware of what that
means, and sort of how to
sort of hone that craft.
Well, we're going to talk
about your short in a bit,
so just hold on to that thought.
But I want to ask Alma--
Alma, when I read your bio
I think of you as an artist.
And I don't know if that's
just my interpretation,
but what led you from
a career in advertising
to a career in entertainment?
I kind of missed what you said--
you see me as an expat?
I wasn't sure what you said?
As an artist.
I mean, that's what your
work brings to mind.
Someone who is really
truly an artist.
Thank you.
Well, I'm also an immigrant.
So I was born in Tel Aviv,
and I was raised there.
I really only came
here at the age of 30,
and it wasn't because I
was pursuing a career.
It was because I was
pursuing my heart.
I was in love with a director
who lived here in Los Angeles
by the name of Boaz Yakin.
And I was already a
director in Israel.
But I've encountered the same
challenges of gender inequality
obviously over there, too, as
many women do around the world.
And it seemed like just every
step had so many kind of levels
to it.
It's not that I didn't want
to make films right away,
but I just had no example of how
to do that and no opportunity
to do that.
I didn't grow up with
a family of artists.
My parents were very
much like blue collar,
I would say creative people,
but definitely their jobs
weren't creative.
And they were just
kind of getting
by month to month paying
rent and things like that.
And were very busy with
that and with issues
of addiction and alcoholism
and things like that.
So really my life was
much more shaped by that.
And I think I found filmmaking
and expression in general
as just a form of--
it was just like a lifeboat.
It wasn't really that I
had a plan and I was like,
I'm going to do this and then
I'm going to go to Hollywood,
or I'm going to be that.
It was just how do I say
something or find a way
to get a sense of self that
would allow me to stop feeling
like I'm sinking all the
time into the same patterns
that I grew up with?
So I guess I started with just
video art and music videos.
And when I came here,
I did music videos
for probably almost 10
years or eight years,
and couldn't even
get to commercials.
And at a certain point, I
just sort of took a camera
and went to the Salton Sea
in California in the desert
and directed a documentary
by myself with no crew.
And it won the
Tribeca Film Festival.
And after that, I
suddenly got opportunities
to direct commercials.
And from there to also meet
other artists and filmmakers
and actors.
Like Shia LaBeouf, who saw
my documentary and admired it
and reached out
to me very kindly.
So it really kind of
opened up everything
when I just kind of took
it into my own hands
and made something that
people can see and appreciate.
But prior to that,
it was just years
of working on I guess
low budget music videos
and having not much of a future
that I could see, you know?
Well, it does sound to me like
from hearing everyone of you
that you have found
yourself, and that you're
in a place where you
understand your craft
and your purpose with your work.
So I just want to ask you at
this point in your career,
how do you want--
what do you want your
work to represent?
How do you want the
world to see your work?
And we can start with you,
Alma, because something you said
prompted me to think about that.
I guess I'm really keen on,
in general as an artist,
I guess finding your own voice
and doing something in a way
that only you can do has always
been sort of my tendency.
Or you could say it's a
dream, but it's also just
like a natural discourse.
Where I almost--
I'd say I'll prefer
to do something
that only I can do than to
make the best whatever, right?
Like a masterpiece.
Like I just really want to
find my voice and the words
to say exactly what
you want to say.
And that's the joy of really
expressing your connection
to life and your existence,
and your relationship
with this world.
And I am also very
drawn, obviously,
from just because
of how I grew up
and where I'm from, to
people that are flawed.
People that are
dealing with hardship,
with difficulties, whether
it's psychological, emotional,
or racial, or financial.
All of those things.
Immigrants, people that weren't
really born with a plan.
Weren't really born with a path.
And I think womenism and
womanhood and feminism
includes all of that, because
so many of us as women
have to really make our
path, and not just find it.
As opposed to finding it--
sometimes we have to make it.
So I guess in my work,
I guess I do find
myself living in that world.
But I'm also really extremely
interested in the subconscious
and dreams and imagination.
So it's really in
the intersection
of all of those things I think
that I find myself operating.
And I just find
sometimes that when
we talk about gender equality,
that there has been somewhat
of a limiting expectation when
we now talk to women directors
to represent a certain
identity for women,
whether it's like only
writing or directing things
that have a certain kind of role
models and things like that.
Even though obviously I couldn't
fight harder and agree more
that we need great
role models on screen
and that it's life
changing for girls,
I also want to see flawed women.
I also want to see women
directing men's stories.
I want to see--
I want to step out of that box
of the expectation of women
only being hired
for certain stories.
Anybody else have that
pressure, feel the pressure
to represent all
womankind in your work?
Or have you really
thought independently--
I'm sure you're all
independent thinkers.
Have you thought
about what you want
to represent in your work
outside of that pressure
when you have that
kind of freedom?
Alma, something you said
really resonated with me
about the whole idea of
role models and everything.
Which is that when Thelma
and Louise came out--
Yes!
The reaction of women that I met
who recognized me on the street
or whatever was so different
from anything I'd experienced.
And they were so passionate
about what it meant to them
and how it impacted them.
And it made me decide--
it made me realize
that we give women
so few opportunities to come
out of a movie feeling inspired
by the female characters.
And men, almost every
movie that comes out,
they can identify with
the male character
and have a vicarious experience.
But it's so rare for women.
So from then on,
I decided that I
wanted to choose roles with the
women in the audience in mind.
What are they going to
think about my character?
How is it going
to make them feel?
And it was very specifically
not about finding role models,
because I'm with you--
I think role model, this whole
idea that female characters
have to be role models
is very limiting.
Flawed, messed up characters,
just like people--
women need to be colorful and
interesting and complicated
characters.
But something I do
look for is women
who are in charge
of their own fate,
or who can become in
charge of their own fate.
And for good or bad, you know.
Make mistakes, or
whatever, but at least
you're driving your own car.
And might be off
the cliff, but--
But that was quite
an awakening for me,
to think about
how we really have
to increase the
opportunities for women
to live vicariously
through characters.
Well, God help us if flawed
people can't be role models.
I don't think there
would be any role models.
So I want to hear also
from you, Laura and Karen.
At this point in your
lives, you done so much
and you've achieved so much.
What do you want the world to
see when they see your work?
You know, I'll answer
it in an odd way,
and in relationship to something
I've just finished working on,
which is a show for HBO
called Lovecraft Country.
And in Lovecraft Country--
and I'll try not to
give anything away--
these women emerge in these
powerful, powerful positions.
And it has been my
honor to score them
with music that's almost
appropriated from a genre that
has been typically male.
And so it's giving
these Black women
what has been perceived of
throughout film scoring history
as white male superhero music.
And to have a woman--
me-- and a Black man--
Rafael Saadiq--
create this music
for these strong
female characters
has been a crazy and really,
really beautiful experience.
And in many ways, it's
playing into genre rather than
away from genre.
So that it's falling
on a lot of the tropes
that we've seen in other kinds
of films that are, as I said,
traditionally male.
And for me it's
been fun, because I
think for really one of
the few times in my career
I've written big movie music.
Big, almost old
fashioned, movie music.
And it's been a real pleasure.
So I mean for me in my life, I
do a lot of different things.
I have concert music,
which is really
kind of a direct vision
of my own personal voice
as a composer.
As a film composer,
it is necessary for me
to take that vision
and take my personality
and do it in service of
great directors, like Alma.
But in this particular case,
the show runner, Misha Green,
who is a genius, wanted us
to play with these genres.
And that has been, I think,
deeply moving and empowering.
Well, when you talk
about empowerment,
that really is what we're
talking about with gender
equity, isn't it?
Karen, you're both a
studio executive as well
now as producer
of creative work.
You can choose either
one, either role--
what do you want your
work to represent?
Well, I got inspired
to come to the industry
because I wanted to
make seminal movies.
And it's the Thelma
and Louises and things
that really just stuck
with you that changed you.
Like on a cellular level,
these movies kind of changed me
as I grew up.
And I wanted to
be a part of that.
I wanted to make movies that
really landed in some way.
And a lot of them moved
the needle in some way
so that they sort of
opened up a perception,
or changed just what I
thought was possible.
Changed my mind about
things, changed my heart.
And so those are the movies that
I really want to keep pushing.
So looking at, like you said,
the traditional male roles--
and thank you, Geena,
for all of your work.
I know you're going
to talk about.
But just to really
go, OK, this would
have been done for a
male, this would have
been done for someone white.
What would it look like for
a person of color or a woman
to inhabit those?
So that they can be as
varied and have the spectrum,
and keep pushing
what that looks like.
And every time, if
it's already been done,
that's not where I want to go.
Although I love, Laura,
what you're saying
is like, OK, it's been
done for men before,
but how do we show it
with a Black female?
Or how do we really push it?
And it opens our minds.
And I think every time we
do movies like that, I just
want to be part of
that conversation
and part of that process.
A couple of you have
alluded to the fact
that you have experienced
gender inequality in this career
that you've had.
And so this is the
discussion of the day.
So let me just ask you a few
questions along those lines,
too, because I
think people really
do think that the fairy tale
is true-- that you get here
and you become successful,
and the path is just
a bed of roses.
I mixed metaphors.
You know, that
it's an easy path.
But it does sound like
you had a lot of work,
and I'm sure you've met
a lot of challenges.
Now, three of you have
started your own organizations
in response to some of the
challenges that you've seen.
And Karen, of course,
you were talking
about working within a
role of a studio exec
to address some of the gender
inequities that you've seen.
But I'd like to hear
from each of you
what was it maybe
that sparked you
to start your organizations?
And Geena, we know
about the number of ways
that gender imbalances occur
in the industry on film.
How did you then decide that you
wanted to do something about it
and start your institute?
Well, so people maybe have
heard this story before,
but when my daughter
was a toddler
and I started showing
her little kids shows
and preschool
things, I immediately
noticed that there seemed
to be far more male
characters than female
characters in the 21st century
in what we're showing to kids.
And I didn't intend
in the beginning
to make it my life's
mission or anything,
but I couldn't find anybody
else who said, I know right?
I noticed, too.
And in fact, when I talked
to people in the industry,
they all said, no, no.
But that's not true anymore.
That's been fixed.
We fixed it.
And I thought, OK.
Nobody sees what
I'm talking about,
and I think this is
profoundly important to fix.
And so I decided I
wanted to get the data.
And the purpose of the
data was very specific,
that rather than
trying to educate
the populace about
this problem, I
wanted to go directly to
the creators very privately
and say, hey, I don't
think you realize this,
but what do you think?
And so that's what we've been
doing for about 15 years.
And it's working directly
in a non-judgemental
and in a supportive
collaborative way to say,
I don't think you realize this,
but how about we improve it?
And your focus was children?
She's being very modest.
Yeah, it's brought huge change.
And those PG-13
especially in movies
that started to inspire you,
it's almost reached parity.
We're still suffering,
but the children movies
have become so much better
with representation.
And I honestly
believe that it goes--
your influence has gone
beyond the movie industry,
well beyond.
I mean, the information
and data is so rich
that it's informed
a lot of the way we
think about work and gender.
And Karen, as I was thinking
about Geena and her work
and what sparked her work
was really her daughter,
and what was her
daughter seeing?
And I'm thinking
about Hair Love.
And as I'm watching, you've
got these three characters.
I don't know how
you captured them--
how they were captured
in such a short film.
But you got a sense of all
three of the characters.
But did you write Hair
Love for children?
Did you write it
for your child self?
I mean, I saw my
child hair story
of being hair shamed
by a white classmate.
I saw that in Hair Love.
So what did you--
how were you thinking about
Hair Love in terms of issues
that children are facing and
getting wrong messages about?
Sure.
I mean, Hair Love
was such a blessing.
And it came to me--
Matthew Cherry, who kind of
got the idea for it-- and it
still surprises
me how many layers
it sort of touches in terms
of my growth as a Black woman.
You know, just so
many things we kind of
poured our hearts into it.
Matthew was seeing online
dads posting about them
doing their daughter's hair.
And the funny thing is-- this
goes to sort of the gender
bias-- is that when women
do their daughter's hair,
that's just a Monday.
But when a dad does
a daughter's hair,
you know it's like, oh
my God, praise the guy.
He did the hair.
And the truth is,
a lot of dads are
doing their daughter's hair.
And so part of what
Matthew wanted to show
is just to normalize that.
So that you really-- and I
think it's really important just
to showcase that, and show
that you can have a man,
a Black man, that fits the
description of tattoos and all
those things that you may
perceive him a certain way,
but you're really
showing that he
can take on sort of
nurturing parental roles just
like the woman.
And so that was really
one of the first ways
that we came into it.
And for me, having two boys,
that was a big part of it.
But then as you said, the
hair was a whole other level.
This is the first time after 20
years in the animation business
that I was sitting in
a room brainstorming
with other people of color
about our experiences,
and how we could put
all of that in us.
And it absolutely took us
all back to our childhood.
And you know, me
growing up in Texas
and being the only Black
girl in my class for years.
And how the pressure
to press your hair
and straighten
your hair, and just
my journey to have
natural hair as an adult.
And so all those
things are sort of what
it meant to shame
your hair, what
it meant to love your hair.
How important it was to
see yourself on the screen.
How important it
was for a father
to kind of listen to
a daughter as she's
sort of trying to sort of
go through her own hair
love journey.
So yeah, it really did
tap into all those things.
And again, it just goes
to the very few images
that are out there.
We were so impressed with
how much people saw it,
and how much they needed it.
And it just really kind of
fuels me to just go crazy,
to just do as many more images
as we can that kind of tap
into those issues.
Well, it resonated on
so many levels with me.
And I told people
who haven't seen it,
just sit down and watch it.
And love having conversations
with people about it.
You know, I had not thought
about women composers
until I met Laura
about two years ago.
And I don't know if you
remember our conversation--
I do.
I cornered you.
You were very clear.
And you might have
spoken about the Alliance
for Women Composers.
I know that visibility was
really important for you.
Has the Alliance been able to
enhance the visibility of women
composers?
I think, shockingly, yes.
I mean, first of all, I
want to go back to Geena
and what she did.
When Geena started
her institute,
we couldn't even
talk about sexism.
Like nobody.
If you were interviewed
in a trade magazine,
someone would say, well, what's
it like being a woman composer?
You literally
couldn't answer it,
because you were afraid
you would never work again.
So Geena really, really
has skin in this game
that is so, so significant.
We're all so unbelievably
grateful to her.
For the Alliance, what happened
is composers were included--
there are a couple of major
researchers in Hollywood,
as I know you know, but Dr.
Martha Lauzen is one of them.
And she included women
composers in her figures
for the first time in 2014.
So numbers don't whine,
and numbers don't lie.
So when you have a number--
and in our case, that year
it was 2% of the top 250 box
office films were
scored by women.
Now we're up to 6%,
which is great, you know?
It's better.
But when you have a number,
then you can go to people.
And it's not like
you're complaining,
but you have something
just to show.
And it's a very,
very simple thing.
And what we did--
I have a good friend who
is a political consultant.
And she said, you
need a directory.
You just need a directory.
And I thought, OK,
well that's easy to do.
Because there were a lot of
us, but nobody knew about us.
So if you were looking for
a woman to score your film,
you would be told by agents
and producers and studios
that there just
weren't any women.
And this is true across the
board for below line talent.
And that was totally
a fiction, as well.
So when we put this
directory together--
and we started with 30, and
now I think there are 700--
that was radical in its own
way by saying, we exist.
And when you're looking for
a woman composer, or a woman
composer who's Latina, or who is
Black, or who lives in Chicago,
we can help you
find that person.
And that, I think, has proved
to be very significant.
And I think as a result also
of an increasing awareness,
I think MeToo.
I think Harvey's
falling and all of that.
Now there are
diversity programs.
Now certain studios have
diversity requirements
in terms of who they pitch.
As you probably know,
the Academy, we just
did new diversity requirements
for the Best Picture.
So there are these things
emerging, which are really,
really significant
and important,
I think will have an impact.
But we still have a tremendous
amount of work to do,
and a long way to go.
Yeah, we do.
But speaking of the
directory, Alma,
you saw a similar need in
starting Free The Work.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, we actually made also a
database, together with Laura,
for composers as part
of our organization.
Yeah.
So are you seeing results
from Free The Work?
And can you tell us a
little bit more about it?
Yeah.
So Free The Work, the way it
started it was Free The Bid.
And the way it started was
in 2016, I was at the time
a commercial director.
It was before I made Honey Boy,
my first feature that got me
the honor to be in the Academy.
But really what was happening
is there was a three bid
system where on every commercial
and every advertisement that
was done, advertising
agencies and brands would have
three directors bid on them.
And it was always three men.
So I was starting to get
really big campaigns,
and noticed that I'm always
bidding against two men.
And there's never any
women around me almost.
Of course, there
were a few, but we
were kind of traveling
in different circles.
Almost every production company
only represented one or two
women in their rosters, and
they would have 10, 20 men.
So I started Free
The Bid, which was
kind of a way to say we're
not demanding you do hire us,
but we're demanding
that you let us bid.
Because the excuse was that
our reels are not big enough.
And it was like, this cycle of
endless lack of opportunity.
Because you can't
make you reel bigger
if you're never even bidding.
So the idea was, OK, we're going
to get all these brands to say,
one of the three
has to be a woman.
And within one year--
and we built a database.
I built a database back
then in my kitchen,
which was on my laptop, which
was just all these directors.
It was about I think 100
directors at the time
when we started.
And within the first
year, we took brands
like HP, who had
zero women directors
on all of their global
campaigns, to 58% women
directors.
And we worked with them
to kind of make sure
that once women were in
the room and got to bid
and got to pitch, a lot of
them obviously got the job.
Because they had great ideas
and they were very competitive,
and they did the work better
than anybody in some cases.
So it made me see the
lack of opportunity
not just for women, but
also for immigrants,
for people of color,
for trans women, which
should be included in this
conversation, and other gender
expressions and preferences.
So we started Free
The Work, and tried
to really bring the same
elements into film and TV.
And our database
now today, we have
partners like Amazon
Studios, Jen Salke,
who's been a really
great partner to us.
And Procter & Gamble,
which almost reached parity
with most of their brands.
And they are the biggest
advertiser in the world.
So we're both in
film and TV, and we
have over 2,000 creators around
the world in 45 countries which
we operate in.
And we also do programs
in those countries,
and we have ambassadors
in each one of them.
And kind of study the
inequality in those places.
But really what it is,
is it's a tool that
allows you to bring tech in the
same way that Spotify, I guess,
is our model in some ways
brought tech into the ability
to search for music.
You could search for directors,
for cinematographers,
for editors, for composers.
And for other below
the line roles
that we're slowly building,
like colorists and editors.
And it kind of
recommends you, also,
artists based on your search.
And you can make
playlists, short lists,
and share them with
your producers.
So it's really a tool for
people to find talent.
When you ask if we make
change, I know we make change.
But I also know that
at the end of the day,
I still get those texts at
11:00 at night from a producer
saying, hey, we really
were told by such and such
that they want us
to hire a woman.
And can you help us find it?
So there's still this
component of whenever
the clock is ticking and
people have less and less time,
somehow they don't write
it into their schedule
to discover talent.
And to discover the women
or the people of color--
Black identified or other.
They're searching for something,
and in the last minute
they find themselves saying,
oh my God, I don't know any.
So it's not-- so I can still
see that it's not a long year
organic process of
people educating
themselves, and
making sure that they
have their favorite directors
in all of those categories.
If I would corner them
and ask them who's
their favorite 10 whatever--
probably all-male.
And then at the
last minute they'll
text me or look at my
site to find somebody
so they can recommend it.
I'm waiting for
the moment where I
want to see the excitement
about discovering talent.
I want to see the excitement
of people about hiring women.
So it's not just a
chore, or something
that you're being pushed
to do because of some--
I think a lot of people
have this idea of,
you know, we can check
the box with women.
As opposed to really be
being engaged and committed
to having better
gender representation.
It's just something that you
have to sort of do, and then
move on to the things that
are more important to you.
There's so much we
haven't covered,
but I really want us to think
about some of the challenges
that we still face.
And one of the things that I
am absolutely certain that we
are all still
facing is a subject
that has been brought
up in different ways,
but that is how do we make
sure that when we say gender
that we're covering the
broad range of gender,
in terms of all
kinds of diversity
that seems to be missing.
And until we have it, we
cannot have full gender equity.
So I want to ask
you, how do we really
begin to have that
full understanding
of what gender means?
How do we-- how does gender
inclusiveness and diversity
figure into your work?
And I'll just start
off by saying,
I heard you mention it,
Laura, in your creative work,
about composing music
for Black women.
And I know, Geena, you have
initiatives that involve
inclusion and diversity.
Can you just tell me more,
each of you tell me more,
about those?
Yeah.
Well, so we have always
used an intersectional lens
when we're talking about this.
You know, it's called--
my institute is on
gender in media,
but really we're looking at
all underrepresented segments
of the population.
Because you know, the goal
is let's start reflecting
the population as it is--
because we judge our
value by seeing ourselves
reflected in the
popular culture.
Oh, there's somebody
that looks like me.
I must be valuable
to this society.
And if you don't see
yourself, you get the message
that you're not worth anything.
And so as you said, I think
it is very, very important
to cast as broad a
net as you possibly
can to define inclusion.
And as you said just
a little bit ago,
it's not just checking a box.
Well, we have a woman now.
So we already did that.
We are fully half
of the population,
and there's all versions
of being a woman
that we need to embrace.
So Karen, one of the things
that you have done recently
is that you have
written a letter that
has become sort of an open
letter to women in animation.
And I will let you tell
us about that letter.
Because the question
that I want to ask,
though, is when you
think of the approach
that you took
women in animation,
is developing allies really
critical when it comes
to creating these inclusive
communities that we all
want to live and work in?
Yes.
I think that that
is the thing that--
things that keep me up
at night are the things
that Alma and Geena
are mentioning.
That we want those--
we want our work to reflect
the world that we live in,
and we know that the people
that are marginalized
understand why they
want a seat at the table
and they want their voice heard.
But until the people that
have the seat at the table
and already have their
voice heard understand it
from a very just gut level
that that has to happen
and they want it,
then we're going
to be putting
requirements and quotas.
Or if there's not women that are
leading and making decisions,
if we're off on a
vacation, what decisions
would be made when we're gone?
It's like how does it become
so systemic in that way
that it just is?
It just is what it is.
I remember, Geena,
when the Institute--
when I was first aware of it,
it seemed so revolutionary.
But it's like, I can't
wait until the future where
it's like, of course.
It's like you don't need it.
You know, it just is what it is.
But the letter you're referring
to was after George Floyd.
Marge Dean, who runs
Women in Animation,
wanted women of color to kind of
speak to how they were feeling.
And you know, how I was
feeling was in Los Angeles,
there were riots and
there were things
that were happening
at The Grove,
and places very close
to us and dear to us.
And sort of the next morning,
one of the newscasters
said, but LA will bounce back.
We always will.
And that's what kind of
just struck my nerve.
Well, part of LA will
bounce back, but what
about the underlying problem?
And you know, again, I've
got two teenage boys that
are roaming the earth now and
doing things that they want
to do, and being silly kids.
And I'm scared every time
they go out of the house.
And you know, what
I was just imploring
is that in every moment
in civil rights movements,
for people of color at least,
it's the non-marginalized,
it's the white
people, that needed
to be allies for the cause when
it really kind of took hold.
And so that really was my
plea to women in animation.
Like we have to
make these changes.
We have to make them
quick and in a hurry.
We have to not be
polite anymore.
We have to sort of be pretty
aggressive about the way
that we do it.
And we need those allies,
and we absolutely need it
in the gender discussion.
And I agree that this is
really bigger than-- you know,
I'm on a counsel at Sony to kind
of respond to the George Floyd
social justice.
But really, we're
talking about sort
of Black numbers in our movies.
But really once we tackle
any marginalized community,
we do the same for--
it's the same struggle, but
we need the majority to really
kind of see it in
the same way that we
know it's as urgent as it is.
Right.
I know, Laura, that when you
became a member of the Academy,
that you were the woman
group in the music group.
How much has changed?
Do you see progress
in the Academy?
I know they're hosting us, but
we can talk frankly about them,
because these dialogues are
about frank conversations.
How much progress have you seen?
And how much do you
think it's still
a case that women are the
only women in the room when
important decisions
are being made,
or discussions are being had?
I think all of it's
true to an extent.
I was admitted to
the Academy in 2015,
and I basically got sponsored
to be a member of the Academy.
I never thought I would
get in, and then I
was going to make a
big stink about it.
That was my big plan.
And then I got in.
But it was something
that I never
felt that I would be included
in, because it was always
very guarded.
and it was an insane idea
to run for governor
after I'd been
a member only for a few months.
But I got into the room.
And what happened
is the first time I
was in on an executive
committee meeting, which
was the kind of smaller groups
associated with each branch,
was the membership meeting.
And I was literally allowed
a seat at the table.
At that point, there
was one other woman
in the world, Siedah Garrett--
great songwriter and lyricist.
She had been the only woman
in the room for 10 years.
So it was me and Siedah,
and they were trying
to make a big diversity push.
And I had brought all
these names to the table.
And the first one
began with a B.
So you go down the
list alphabetically.
So right off the bat,
my first academy meeting
I had to strongly advocate
for a woman composer.
And what I had to do with
that time was explain--
because her credits
were being dismissed
as not being Academy worthy.
And what I had to explain was
her credits in the playing
field that we are
given were massive.
And I pointed to
the guys and I said,
this is like you scoring a Pixar
film, the fact that she scored
this film and it won Sundance.
It's that big a deal.
And so I was able to kind of--
and it was painful--
but I was able to
educate a roomful of men
about the differences between
what we were at that point
allowed to do and the
opportunities that they had.
And I think honestly as
a result of that meeting,
I was elected governor.
Because I think that
my branch realized
that there was a real
need for this, and because
of the advocacy work that I'd
done through the Alliance.
But I have to say
that at that point,
I'd been an advocate
sort of very publicly
for about three or four years.
And in that moment in that three
hours of the Academy meeting,
I felt that I had done
more good than I'd
done in the entire three years
before, because of the level
that I was playing at.
So I, with a lot of
really wonderful men
and now women-- because all
those women that were admitted
are now sitting on that
executive committee, right?
So that's how it really happens.
You know, that
you get people in,
and then you get them a seat
at the table, literally.
And then changes happen.
And you find these ways that
you can expand the rules.
For example, we
started a short list,
because I and
other people really
believed that by
having a short list,
you could see more diversity in
that short list instead of just
the five nominees.
So last year we had Michael
Abels, we had Kathryn Bostic.
We had people who might not
have been amplified if only
the nominees were amplified.
So I think it's been, for me,
working in an institution has
been really interesting.
Because you figure out
how to navigate the rules,
change the ones that you
need to change, and then
make them work for you in order
to push the field forward.
And I do think that an
Academy membership has
been really helpful to people.
It elevates people.
And so it's been good work.
The board room is
way more diverse
than it was when I
got there, in terms
of people of color and women.
It's much, much better.
And we've had some
big victories.
And now it's time
to turn the page
and to move to the next stage.
And what I've always
said is that I
want the Alliance to grow
bigger than you can possibly
imagine in five years, and
then we want to be gone.
Because at some
point, all of us want
to stop talking
about this, right?
All of us want to go
beyond continuing to need
to have this conversation.
So the goal is to have a
completely equal playing field,
where you're known for,
oh, she did this score.
Or oh, she made that
movie and I love it,
so let's hire her
to do this or that.
That's where we all want to get.
And it's wonderful to
have these conversations,
and I can't wait until
we stop having them, too.
It's almost as
though you're saying,
I want to work my
way out of the job.
Yeah.
Out of the-- certainly I want
to keep composing until nobody
wants to hear from me anymore.
But I think we all want
to work our way out
of the advocacy
jobs, and go back
to being full time artists.
But in fact, that's
impossible to do
until we've opened
this thing up,
and we've cleared the
pipeline for younger women
and underrepresented people.
And we see people at
the top doing whatever
work they want to do
without being typecast
or having their qualifications
constantly questioned.
I'm going to end
with two questions--
one word questions.
And they are this--
first of all, in one
word, where do you
want to see more gender balance?
Secondly, what gives you hope?
So those two questions,
you can think about those.
And you had a comment, Alma.
Actually, my comment is actually
an answer to your question.
So I should have just
been patient and waited.
But I am an Israeli,
so we always
jump ahead and lack those
talents of being patient.
So yeah, my answer is actually
exactly what you were saying.
Because Laura said something
so important to me, which
is she said, we can't wait
to go back to being an artist
full time and not need to
necessarily do the advocacy.
And I think a lot of artists
and a lot of filmmakers
that do the work feel the
toll of needing to activate
the parts of their brain
and their social skills
and their advocacy and
activism that sometimes often
really bite into their
time of being an artist.
And they start to question
themselves, who am I right now?
And the thing that really has
touched me this year, when
we speak about institutions
and organizations--
we just spoke about
the Academy, but I
had the honor to win
a DGA award this year
as a director for Honey Boy.
And when I was there,
I really kind of
took the time, the few
minutes I had on stage,
to speak about the Parenthood
Penalty campaign, which
I was part of and
I know Geena, I
believe you also were
part of that campaign.
And you asked where else we want
to see this gender equality,
and really to me it's
kind of like it's not just
about the representation.
It's not just about
finding the talent.
It's about really understanding
that the whole system is
rigged.
That everything was
built by men for men.
And for all of us to
really thrive and allow
for these talents,
past their first film
or past their experiences that
kind of get them discovered
or seen, how do they
survive past that when
women lose their health
insurance in their most
vulnerable year?
Because the way the
insurance was built
is that if you do not show up
enough in that year on sets,
you lose it if you
don't have enough days.
And the fact that
parenthood in general
is being looked at as
something that just women do,
as opposed to men, too.
So I think what we
have to look at is--
and where I would love to
see more gender equality--
is not just in
discovering the talent,
but making sure that that
talent has a sustainable career.
That the things that
are supposed to support,
that are already supporting
men, would support also
underrepresented creators,
whether it's people of color,
or of certain social economical,
or immigrants, or women,
trans women.
And all these people that really
don't have a chance sometimes,
even once they get
discovered, because
of all sorts of things that
we're not taking into account.
So more-- I'm going
to chalk that up
as more balance toward
parenting responsibilities.
I'm looking at--
a system is made up of parts.
So what are the parts
that you all see?
And you've mentioned
parenting and being
a penalty for parenting.
So that's just one
part of the system.
There are many parts, and I
think we think of the system.
But it's hard for
people at times
to really comprehend
the entire system.
And so sometimes it's
important for people to think,
what is the one part that I
know needs to be more fair, more
inclusive, better
resourced, in order
to improve gender balance?
Any other examples that
any of you could give?
I have a kind of a little bit
of a different answer in that I
want--
when you're talking
about the Academy,
I want voters to appreciate
the female aperture.
And I think that sometimes it's
difficult for people to see.
And the thing that struck
me is at the end of Little
Women, which really
had incredible moments
from the female aperture, she
gives the baby to the husband
as she's walking.
Do you guys remember that scene?
This is-- I can't remember
the year of Little Women,
but let's say it's 1870 or 1872.
She gives the baby to the
husband, who's got the thing--
speaking of parenting--
on his chest,
you know, that they
put the baby into.
That was such a moment of
female aperture and celebration.
Gives the baby to the husband,
and then joins her sisters.
And I think that people
are not understanding
what women and all kinds
of underrepresented groups
are bringing to the table.
And sometimes it can
be super obvious,
and sometimes it
can be super subtle.
And I think that
this is when you
look at the diversity
of experience,
and sort of the diversity
of the human condition.
This is how it really can affect
our field and what we're doing.
These apertures are
really significant,
and I appreciate
them when I see them.
And I think other
people do, too.
In terms of the hope--
my students.
I mean, I teach at USC.
The women are so aware.
They support each other.
They feel supported.
They know they
have a place to go
in terms of in my particular
field, the Alliance, or Women
in Film and other organizations
that have been started.
And they're aware,
and they know what
they're getting
into, which I think
is a really good
thing at this point.
Right.
I would say that my theory is
that if it happens on screen,
it will happen in real life.
And that's why I'm
so focused laser
like on onscreen depictions.
And I mean, we
know things like--
it's just that media images
have an incredible power
to normalize things.
And we know that there are
so many more women than men
now in forensic science,
for example, because of CSI.
Women saw it on TV and
said, wow, I could do that.
Another interesting
thing was in 2012
after Hunger Games and
Brave both came out,
girls' participation
in archery skyrocketed
to be the most
populated category
of competitive archery,
because they saw it.
And they said, oh wow, I
guess girls can do that.
Also when I got to play
the president on TV--
I had very brief
administration sadly,
but research found that after
the show had been on people
were 58% more likely to
vote for a female candidate
for president.
And so we really do
need to take advantage
of the power of these images
to transform the world.
And I would say, maybe
because it's the rooms I'm in,
we unfortunately have an
ability as the deciders,
decision makers
for these projects,
you could talk about let's say
we're doing an Israeli project.
There's still a weird problem
where you don't look around
the room and go, wait a minute.
I'm not Israeli.
I need Israeli
people in the room.
And it's got to be as crazy
as when we see cigarettes
in movies now that
just look insane,
it's got to feel that weird.
If you're in a room you
have to have inclusion.
So I don't know, I
want systemic inclusion
where that's just a normal thing
that anybody would feel insane
talking about something without
that person in the room.
And I also have hope, because
I think the kids get it.
And they want it and
are demanding it,
and we need to just give them
power to help us through this.
And your hope, Geena?
Oh, my hope is that we can
make this change happen fast.
You know, that in the time it
takes to create a new TV show
or create a new
movie, we can change
what the future looks like.
You know, we don't have to
sneak up on this problem.
We can make wholesale
change right away,
particularly on screen.
The easiest place to do it.
And things will
change if we do that.
That's great.
Well, let me just say I have
hope because of all of you,
and the work that you're doing.
I have spent the entire
weekend really thinking
about the court, and the
loss that we are experiencing
right now in terms of Ruth
Bader Ginsburg and her absence.
And the absence of her voice,
her aperture, from the court.
But what you give me
is hope that change
is happening in other places.
And I believe that it has
to happen in all places.
It can't just take place in
one part of the government,
or one part of industry.
And I don't think
there's any industry that
has the influence
and the power to make
it happen in other places than
in the entertainment industry.
So I am hopeful that gender
equity will be a reality,
and I know that you will
all be contributing to it.
So thank you, and thanks
for this conversation.
Thank you.
Thanks, everybody.
Hi, I'm Geena Davis.
Thank you for watching
Academy Dialogues.